so i have two two-dimensional vectors
right over here vector a and vector b
and what i want to think about is what
how can we define or what would be a
reasonable way to define the sum of
vector a
plus vector b
well one thing that might jump at your
mind is look well each of these are two
dimensional they both have two
components why don't we just add the
corresponding components so for the sum
why don't we make
the first component of the sum just the
sum of the first two components of these
two vectors so why don't we just make it
six
plus
negative four well six plus negative
four is equal to two and why don't we
just make the second component the sum
of the two second components so negative
two
plus four is also equal to two so we
start with two two dimensional vectors
you add them together you get another
two two dimensional vectors if you think
about it in terms of real coordinate
spaces both of these are members of r2
i'll write this down here just so we get
used to the notation
so vector a
vector a
and vector b
are both members of r two
are both
members of r2 which is just another way
of saying that these are both two tuples
they're both two dimensional vectors
right over here
now this might make sense just looking
at how we represented it but how does
this actually make visual or conceptual
sense and to do that let's actually plot
these vectors let's try to represent
these vectors in some way let's try to
visualize them so vector a
we could
visualize this tells us how far this
vector moves in each of these directions
horizontal direction and vertical
direction so if we put the
i guess you could say the tail of the
vector at the origin remember we don't
have to put the tail of the origin but
that might make it a little bit easier
for us to draw it we'll go 6 in the
horizontal direction 1 2 3 4 5 6 and
then negative 2 and the vertical so
negative 2.
so vector a
vector a
could look like this
looks like
that and once again
the important thing is the magnitude and
the direction the magnitude is
represented by the length of this vector
and the direction is the direction that
is pointed in and also just to emphasize
i could have drawn vector a like that
or
i could have put it over here these are
all
these are all equivalent vectors these
are all equal to vector a all i really
care about is the magnitude and the
direction
so with that in mind let's also draw
vector b
in the horizontal direction goes
negative four one two three four and in
the vertical direction goes four one two
three four so it's tail if we start at
the origin
if his tail is at the origin its head
would be at four
it would be at negative four four so let
me draw that
just like that
so that right over here
is vector b
and once again vector b we could draw it
like that or
we could draw it
so let me copy
let me paste it so this would also be
another way to draw vector b this would
also be another way to draw vector b
once again what i really care about is
its magnitude and its direction all of
these green vectors have the same
magnitude they all have the same length
and they all have the same direction
so how does the way that i've drew
vector a and b gel with the what its sum
is so let me draw its sum like this let
me draw some in this blue color and it's
a blue color so the sum based on how on
this definition we just use a vector
addition would be 2 2
so 2 2 so it would look it would look
something
it would look like this
so how does this make sense that the sum
that this purple vector plus
this green vector is somehow going to be
equal to this blue vector i encourage
you to pause the video and think about
if that even makes sense
well one way to think about it is this
first purple vector it shifts us this
much it takes us from this point to that
point and so if we were to add it let's
start at this point and put the green
vector's tail right there and see where
it's where it ends up putting us so the
green vector we've already have a
version so once again we start at the
origin the red the vector a takes us
there now let's start over there with
the green vector and see where green
vector takes us and this makes sense
vector a plus vector b put the tail of
vector b at the head of vector a so if
you were to start at the origin vector a
takes you there then if you add on what
vector b takes you it takes you right
over there so relative to the origin how
much did you
how much did you i guess you could say
shift and once again vectors don't only
apply to things like displacement it
complied at velocity comply to actual
acceleration it can apply to a whole
series of things but one when you
visually visualize it this way you see
that it does make complete sense this
blue vector the sum of the two
is what results where you start with
vector a
at that point right over there vector a
takes you there then you take vector b's
tail start over there and it takes you
to the tip of the sum
now one question you might be having is
well vector a plus vector b is this but
what is vector b what is vector b
plus vector a
plus vector a does this still work
well based on the definition we had
where you add the corresponding
components you're still going to get the
same
sum vector so it should come out the
same so this will just be negative 4
plus 6 is 2
4 plus negative 2 is 2.
but does that make visual sense so if we
start with vector b so let's say you
start right over here vector b takes you
right over there
and then if you were to if then if you
were to go there and you would start
with vector a so let's do that
so actually let me let me make this a
little bit let me actually start with a
new
a new vector
b so let's say that that's our vector b
right over there
and then if actually give us a place
where i'll have some space to work with
so let's say that's my vector b right
over there
and then let me get my a copy of the
vector a
that's a good one
so copy and let me paste it so i could
put vector a's tail at the tip of vector
b
and then it'll take me
right
over there
so if i start here
if i start
if i start right over here vector b
takes me there and now i'm adding to
that vector a which will take me
starting here will take me there and so
from my original starting position i
have gone
i have gone this far
now what is this vector well this is
exactly the vector 2
2 or another way of thinking about it
this vector shifts you 2 in the
horizontal direction and to
in the vertical direction so either way
you're going to get the same result and
that should hopefully make visual or
conceptual sense as well